cole stewart is the starting pitcher for
the cubs today
and a triple a this year iowa four
starts one and two and a 368 era 22
innings of work
number four overall pick in the 2013
draft just a couple of spots behind
chris bryant three and two payoff pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out
welcome to the north side cole stewart
some good tailing action on that
fastball
chris paddock on the mound for the
padres getting his tenth start of the
season
improvement a great may so far for chris
paddock we documented that in our
pregame hit
starts his 10th game points hitting 227.
two balls two strikes to peterson
leading it off
you're in the bottom of the first inning
and a swing and a miss
paddock strike shot peterson a good
start for chris paddock one down
everything worked out at that quickly
ahead
off speed stuff they really tried to
keep it in both in milwaukee
and in houston starting to see some
patterns there's a hot shot to short
by his picks and low throw gets by
bryant
and tatis will take second base
so a good pick by buyers had plenty of
time
because it was hit so hard he just threw
it away into the dirt and
brian could not dig it out and tati
sends up at second base
fernando at third base one away and will
myers coming up no score
in the top of the second and he swings
here lines one the other way
and into right field for a base hit
fernando comes in to score and the
padres take a one-nothing lead on an
unearned run
in the top of the second inning javi
baez error
costs chicago just a nice piece of
hitting a little two seam action
coming back towards the outer half of
the plate
and will does a nice job punching this
ball to right field
they're coming in and a swing of the
miss fastball that is strikeout number
two
for chris paddock first down to the
second inning
with authority the old number one
here's the 3-2 pitch swing and a miss
great change up down and paddock gets
out of it with a strikeout
couple in the inning for paddock no runs
a hit and two left in scoring position
by the cubs go to the third inning at
wrigley
regardless of the velocity the cubs
offense been much improved from last
year
six in the league in runs per game
three-two for paddock
and that's line to center pro far coming
on gangs he can't get it
and it's gonna roll brian on the move
chris racing around
second on his way to third and bryant's
gonna have a triple
the do or die play in pro far laid out
and it turns into a three-bagger
yeah i'm sure if profile had a mulligan
could do it all over again he'd play
this on a hop and hold chris bryant to a
single there's two outs and nobody on no
need to really
be overly aggressive on a ball like this
he thought he could make a play on it
javier baez at the plate cubs trailed
one to nothing
but 3-2 swing on hit in the air deep
left-center
it's got a chance gone
javier baez with a monstrous home run
just to the left of dead center probably
about
460 feet pubs lead 2-1
one of the few pitches paddock is thrown
in the middle of the plate javi waits on
it
and doesn't try to hook this ball he
hits at the straightaway center
and this is an absolute bomb and welcome
back
to wrigley field our fans they get
treated to a blast from bias
[Applause]
ground ball softly hit and a throw to
first there's an out there now
tag play and they're going to tag out
fernando no indication
from the second base umpire scott berry
and he's still standing out there
actually see if the cubs are gonna
challenge this smart base running move
out there yeah now like donnie said the
tag play
is in effect he's saying he's safe yeah
so
we'll see if the cubs are going to
challenge this apparently they are not
oh how many times do we see fernando
do this he is safe he's calling himself
safe
padres run a lot lead major league
baseball with 59 stolen bases
[Applause]
look what i found behind the back
stewart didn't even know the ball was in
his glove now that's a play
he caught it behind him a one hop smash
up the middle
he looked in the glove and said i'll be
darned that's a baseball
the cubs get 39.5
of their runs on homers that one drilled
center field
pro far back back some more looking
patrick wisdom blasts one off the
batter's eye
[Applause]
home run dependent today they'll take it
and for wisdom
his second resent my goodness
wisdom and strength and power
a towering blast so that'll bring up
chris bryant with one out here in the
fifth inning in the cubs leaving the
padres
three to one paddock delivers bryant
swings and hits one in the air to deep
right field
going back is myers at the track leaps
it's in the basket
a two-run shot for chris bryant cubs
extend the lead 5-1 over the padres here
in the fifth
kb gets a heater out over the plate and
i do believe he knows he's not going to
get anything to pull in yet back
so he's prepared to hit this ball away
he does
gets it up in the wind myers goes back
and back and ends up at the ivy
two down nobody on in the batter is
fernando tati is junior
fly ball right center field in deep hat
going back and it is
very gone how to deep right center field
at wrigley for fernando tatis jr
his 16th and the padres pick up their
second run
that's the fernando tatis junior zone at
wrigley field remember his longest home
run of his career is up in that area
this one may have a chance to break that
stay tuned to that
up and away takes it that way he knows
it just a matter of how far is it going
to go
patrick wisdom that smoked
out towards right center pro far back at
the
wall and it's gone his second of the day
patrick wisdom two homers
third of the season
and the cubs on top it's now 6-2
here's the 1-0 and uh ground ball
sharply to the right side cronin worth
diving stop throws from his knees in
time
peterson's out and he can't believe it
jock just flipped his helmet off as he
crossed first base
because jake cronenworth just robbed him
not only of a base hit but an rbi
i like you coming out of playing gm well
by the way i come out and i say things
i have been up here and said trade this
one oh
what do you got left field
number two his second of the day
and that one was as high as it was far
hey
on the day and it is all
cubs using the home run ball here today
i gotta tell you between baez and tati
you really are looking at the two most
entertained
great players in the game one of my
favorite cups
[Applause]
inside corner ball game nice work
tommy nance cubs win